hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video back on foreign again today there
was a little bit of info talked about
the open test the new upcoming roadmap
and stuff like that so as always let's
get started with today's video so first
up the open test is live so enjoy which
has all the heroes including the Wulin
heroes breach mode and all through maps
and tons more things only on PC remember
you don't have to own the game on PC to
play it you can all you have to do is
just make sure your PC is able to run it
and then you can play it with tons of
other people
shortly after this video I will be
making a guide on Jang Joon I'm almost
done with the video and once that's done
I'm probably going to be going live for
a couple hours showing off the mode and
playing it just for some fun so if you
guys want to come on by the stream
definitely check it out it should be a
very shortly after this goes live and
then next up they showed the four on a
road map on the September Road map it
showed the open test which I just
mentioned a double xp fest on September
14th going for about a week and ends
with a ton of other challenges as well
and then duel tournaments in there a
couple weeks and as well as like I said
tons of other things coming in this road
map so nothing too crazy but we did get
double xp which is pretty cool and also
there's two things that they didn't
mention that are actually going to be
coming to the game and that is one big
signatures there's a video on reddit of
them showing off the victor victory
celebration screen
there's no way like I said a victory
celebration screen after every match I'm
pretty sure that might just have to do a
breach maybe it's Dominion 4 before
modes I'm not entirely sure what
specific modes there are but I'm pretty
sure it's just the four of you four
modes but it's your entire team and
they're all kind of dancing and
celebrating and stuff but there's a new
type of content of the week eventually
coming in the future called signatures
and if you have the open test it's right
next to the emotes tab and there's going
to be new signatures coming to the game
which will show off the new you know new
signature so instead of your guy you
know waving his shield in the air maybe
he'll throw it on the floor or do do
different types of animations for the
emote screen which is really nice and
cool and on top of that Raider actually
got a buff in the open test as it
credited by Freese on his one frame data
video he did say that now a Raider now
gets a guaranteed side heavy off of a
guard break and making that do 40 damage
so big buff to the Raider players there
the actual content of the week in the
actual game is mythic outfits 15,000
steal each the Knights gate cordyceps
Vikings have Swampert and
samurai getcha Boko these are the
weirdest names I've ever seen but the
mythic outfits aren't really that great
they're not bad but they're not the
greatest we've had some better ones
released before but if you want it it's
15k a steal so definitely go get it if
you want
and then lastly they talked about the
voice lines come in a for honor but you
most likely heard of them already most
people are in an uproar about it and
that's why it's in the open test so if
they don't like it they can change it I
was like I said I've seen I read it tons
of people talking about hobby the voice
acting is absolute garbage so if a lot
of people don't like it they might
change it so that it becomes way better
when the actual game releases via guys
really quick a video and not too much on
the dev stream it's mostly because the
most important thing is the open test
I'm assuming once the open test is gone
this weekend next week will start
getting a lot more info on stuff like
that and then of course we're gonna get
tons more info coming to the next coming
up on the season 8 because we're almost
done I believe runs we're almost on
campaign three which is really nice
we're almost there with that yeah let me
know what you guys think about the
victory celebration screen the voice
lines have you played the open test the
new characters anything I mentioned
today I love to know your thoughts
especially the Raider buff as well so
the Raider players but I like to be if
you do enjoy subscribe if you're new I
cover the informational side of forum
and that being balance changes hero
updates patch notes all that type of
stuff and I thought guys hope every
great rester day I think for watch the
video and peace out
[Music]